the easing of sanctions came as mali's
military junta indicated willingness to
hold elections earlier
malice military rulers want to have
echoes on their side as they deal with
huge security and economic challenges
after a
discussion
the head of state took
the following decision the first decided
to
lift
all the economic and financial sanctions
that were taken
on january 9 2022. easing echoes
economic and financial blockade will be
welcomed by people in landlord to mali
this will mean the resumption of
cross-border trade and air travel with
malice neighbors and beyond this
eventually could lead to closer
cooperation with the bloc in tackling
insecurity
i would like to thank you this was
highlighted at the opening of the summit
when ghanaian president nana akova ado
voiced the collective concern of member
states
these terrorist attacks
are now not only focusing on the sahel
but also expanding to the coastal states
in our region
it is imperative for us
to continue to implement our regional
action plan
against terrorism and to coordinate our
various security
initiatives
but while the intervention in mali
brings hope similar attempted mediation
failed in guinea forcing the echoes
envoy to quit for lack of progress
in contrast to guinea we see that in
mali and in burkina faso
the military authorities are engaging at
high political level with echoes and
voice and that is a positive sign
towards finding
a
mutually agreed transition
to democratic governors
echoes also agreed to give burkina faso
two years to transition back to
democracy and is pulling out its
stabilization force in guinea-bissau
after a successful
ahmed idris al jazeera accra ghana